so i've i've come to just you know
accept that as a part of like just this
universe of lord of the rings expression
that continues to expand and grow and
you know it's people send me these
things occasionally i'm like have you
seen this i'm like no but you know
that's funny thanks
it's done
oh my gosh but it's so nice to see you
and this movie was so delightfully
creepy oh my god
delightfully creepy i mean yes it is it
is it is creepy press record and let's
get this party started
it is february 13th 1986. this is agent
bill hagmaier i'm sitting with theodore
ted
i'm sitting with ted bundy
well of course everyone knows ted bundy
such an infamous man but it really feels
like there has been such a resurgence of
late in hollywood about his story what
was it about this script in particular
that you were like this is the one you
know obviously we we found the script
not sort of you know in the in the
throngs of
uh of the focus on on ted bundy it just
weirdly happened in the zeitgeist in the
in the span of time of trying to get the
movie made but
we we were just fascinated by this
particular story that felt
it was it was a part of his life and a
story that i'd not heard before um
i didn't know about his relationship
with bill hagmeyer i didn't know about
these four years their conversations and
ultimately you know a significant enough
relationship that ted felt that bill was
his best friend he referred to him as
his best friend at the end of his life
and wield his last earthly possessions
to bill when he died in particular also
what was intriguing was the fact that
the conversations that take place in the
film are largely based on transcripts
and and recollections of bill they're
incredibly accurate and that was really
exciting
and it also talked about a time in his
life that hadn't really been covered and
i think that was also interesting to us
you think you're smarter than him
you think you're going to be the one
that's going to get him to confess what
i don't think i'm smarter sir
i don't think you necessarily have to be
smarter getting to play a character
that's based off of a real person can be
there's so many different facets to it
it can be extremely daunting for an
actor it can also be extremely rewarding
what kind of behind the scenes prep were
you doing in order to step into this
man's shoes
yes it can be definitely daunting and
rewarding um i mean
the only thing that's unfortunate about
the timing of the making of the film is
that we made it as a covid compliant
film last summer
so we weren't able to travel
initially we had planned on traveling
east to spend time with bill um so i
didn't actually get to meet bill i
haven't met him in person yet
but i have spoken to him on the phone
but obviously you know it was important
to me
that i do him justice and the main thing
that i wanted to know was just simply
what does it take to walk into a room
with someone like that what were you
thinking what was the preparation and i
just wanted to get those things right um
you know was there any sense of anxiety
and you know i had such an extraordinary
actor in luke kirby to work opposite you
know his embodiment of ted was so
uncanny and incredible
um that it it it made my job so much
easier to work opposite him was a was a
joy every day there are a lot of myths
and misunderstandings about me
what are you going to tell me everything
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
and we did a fair amount of you know
planning ahead of time obviously on zoom
not in person um but we you know those
scenes are intricate and there's a lot
being said that's not being said um
they're sort of like these psychological
chess games and it was really fun for us
to break those things down do some sort
of script analysis and and work out sort
of the architecture of those scenes
prior to doing them um and then just you
know delve into that space and and let
them kind of take on a life of their own
we've seen so many incredible characters
from you throughout your career my
personal favorite is wilfred oh that's
amazing i love wilfred too am i dead
ah
sam's not we are in the day and age of
reboots and reunions if you could step
back into the shoes of one of your past
characters who would you choose and why
oh wow you know that everyone's just
screaming frodo right now
sure i mean look if i had that
experience to do over again
in a heartbeat like spend the better
part of four years in new zealand again
with those people making those films you
know i didn't want it to end you know we
we
principal photography was 16 months and
then we went back each year for
additional shooting um for for pickups
and reshoots
and that kind of lulled us into this
false sense of security because we're
like oh we get to go back every year um
i would have gladly kept shooting i i
loved it that's an obvious answer though
so let me think of something i mean
something that got cut short that i
would have loved to have continued was
dirk gently actually have you ever
actually solved the case sure tons well
summer i really loved playing todd
playing that character
like
this sort of
reluctant
kind of you know this person that's sort
of in the midst of the the the sort of
massive insanity storm that is dirk
gently uh the sort of foil to his comedy
i guess was just a joy i had so much fun
playing that character i had so much fun
in that world
um the cast was great yeah i would have
loved to have seen that carry on um
because we just had a lot of fun making
that show and it felt like there were so
many other stories we could tell one
thousand percent circling back to what
you just said of how like you didn't
want to leave new zealand
is there an open invitation for you to
go to the amazon lord of the rings
series like if they were to invite you
would you go just to see what's going on
uh to just check it out sure yeah yeah i
mean there would there would certainly
be no place for frodo wagons in those
stories
but yeah i mean you know i know i've met
uh bayana the the j.a bayana who's
directing the pilot i think he's
directed probably the first two episodes
um i've known him from sort of spanish
friends in this spanish film community
and he's lovely uh
but yeah i mean you know to visit and
see what it is that they're doing in
that universe and in that space is super
fascinating to to visit for sure i just
love that not only have the movies lived
on but now you are in many memes that
it's finally done people will use that
constantly like how does it feel knowing
that you're living on just an internet
lore
i mean there's so much of that
ephemera
that has continued to express itself or
i mean started expressing itself
relatively soon after the films were
initially released
so i've i've come to just you know
accept that as a part of like just this
th this universe of lord of the rings
expression that continues to expand and
grow and you know it's people send me
these things occasionally like have you
seen this i'm like no but you know
that's funny thanks you know it's it's
just like just because i'm the star of
the meme doesn't mean you need to send
it to me
but it it's funny because i actually
don't see a lot of it like for instance
the keep your secrets thing which became
a mean people asked me about it and i
hadn't seen it so people were
referencing it like it was a pop culture
thing which it clearly was but i hadn't
seen it and i think it's partially
because i
my experience on
twitter i'm not really on facebook
i don't i'm not exposed to that many
memes maybe so i think i just totally
missed it um and maybe i miss a lot of
it and maybe that's for the best
it's done
well my last question for you is of
course fans know and love you as frodo
but i loved you as jace and star wars
the resistance
mega movie franchise would you like to
join next because we've got you in the
star wars world we've done lord of the
rings marvel the harry potter films like
does any of that appeal to you
i mean honestly
um
yeah totally uh
to play and the thing about like marvel
films and you know certainly the star
wars universe too
it's to play in a large sandbox and i
think that's just inherently fun
and i haven't i haven't had a chance to
play in a giant sandbox in a while and
so any of those would be awesome i mean
star wars gets precedence because i'm a
huge star wars fan so more of that
certainly a live action sphere would be
awesome but i mean yeah working on a
marvel film
i mean you know there's obviously like
a whole conversation that happens
certainly in film twitter about the sort
of
the cinematic relevance of marvel uh is
it cinema all this sort of
and you know whether you like superhero
movies or not they are inherently fun
and those movies are extremely well made
and i think
getting to play again in that universe
of sandbox would be a blast would be
totally awesome because it's just at
such an insane scale you know it's
awesome